tomorrow is International Nurses Day boy
do they deserve it and people across
America are finding new and creative
ways to show their support for our
health care heroes this mural on the
side of one South Florida Hospital is a
towering tribute to those medical
workers and Americans affected by the
virus Manuel Bojorquez has the story of
the artist and the impact of her work
Claudia LaBianca is well known in miami
street art scene her murals celebrate
strong and empowered female characters
drawing inspiration from the comic book
heroes who gave her comfort when she was
bullied as a child in her native Italy
in March like everyone else the Cova
docked down really through claudia for a
loop I can't go anywhere I can't paint a
mural I can't do nothing and I'm going
crazy what did you do
I stole my daughter's iPod and I did an
illustration of the nurses being
superheroes so with their capes flowing
and with their stance of a strength of
power these people are going out there
as superheroes to go and save lives and
take care of the sick ones
Claudia then printed posters and
delivered them to area hospitals hoping
to give a little lift to overburdened
medical workers at one hospital the
night shift got creative and went for
the live-action recreation you know it
was fun South Florida remains a kovat
hotspot emergency rooms and icy use
filled with stress doctors and nurses
coping with far too many lost patients
and also far too many lost colleagues
Claudia recalls an early morning text
from one nurse at the end of an
especially tough night she looked up and
she saw these posters she start crying
and right away yes from her contact
she tax me and she told me like that the
image took her from a bad day it's a
good day indeed shooing back inspired
and that in turn inspired Claudia to go
big
well not exactly spider-man she did
spend the past eight days perched on the
side of a hospital wall creating the
largest mural she's ever done a one
hundred and four foot Technicolor shout
out these people are saving life you
know when you think of a superhero what
do they do the superhero with the cape
and the mask what do they do they're
going there they're fighting they're
fighting the enemy right so who's the
enemy now there will be five hospital
installations in all and if the mural is
the message this one speaks to the
resilience dedication and courage of
those on the front line heroes who pass
by every day on their way to work I wish
I loved half as good as those men and
women up there I mean she did a really
great job it is it's absolutely
beautiful
it's a little inspirational what's it
been like for you to hear that the best
feeling ever and to see them walking by
and cheering up and smiling thank ya I
mean I can see their smile through their
masks you know they're all down there
jumping it's the best feeling ever
I never been this happy in the end it
took about 300 cans of paint to create
this 100 foot mural and cost about
thirty thousand dollars to produce you
can even see it from some of the local
highways and even though it is just
paint on a wall it is proven meaningful
for the doctors nurses and other
personnel who work at this hospital the
power of art Tony oh man you're so right
it's so much more than just paint on the
wall and I love so much about the
project starting with the fact that
social workers were included we don't
often mention social workers and all
this but they're important as well but
it's an opportunity for these doctors
and nurses to not only be seen and
appreciated but also when they're posing
and copying the mural to have a moment
of fun as well which they desperately
need on top of everything else all right
thank you very much